zone Europe sur sensation avec le
soutien financier du Fonds citoyen
franco-allemand bonsoir et bienvenue
dans zone Europe sur Radio sensation en
association avec TV 78 un numéro spécial
franco-allemand pour cette émission je
suis avec les sens à reporter qui ont
répondu à l'appel de candidature cet été
pour une émission avec le soutien du
fond citoyen franco-allemand il y a par
exemple Amélie caille Esther de radio
campbert AHF andburg où nous aurons
l'occasion d'aller pour un prochain
numéro alors je crois que l'une d'entre
vous parle un petit peu français alors
comment c'est passé ce séjour en France
le 3 jours à France est très super
j'aime visiter radio sensation
vous êtes notamment aussi aller
interroger des Français sur les clichés
qui entouraient les Allemands on regarde
tout de suite ce que ça donne quelle
image avez-vous des Allemands quels sont
les idées reçues que vous avez sur les
Allemands
[Musique]
mais de manière générale depuis là reste
et en existe partout mais moi de mon
côté ça en j'en connais pas et j'en ai
pas entendu parler tu sais pas des
clichés c'est des résultats de situation
politique et autres c'était nos ennemis
il y a très longtemps
elle paraît très agressive je sais pas
vraiment si ce qu'il pense en fait
c'est plutôt amélioratif j'imagine c'est
qu'ils sont très travailleurs
et donc très investi dans leur travail
primordial et même indispensable pour
entretenir l'amitié franco-allemande et
lutter contre les idées reçues ce sont
les jumelages je le disais vous êtes
originaire d'achat finborg ça se trouve
en Bavière en Allemagne donc et cette
ville est jumelée avec
Saint-Germain-en-Laye dans les Yvelines
vous avez posé quelques questions à
Christina Lang deotti elle est
vice-présidente du jumelage entre
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et achaffelbourne
il y a 2200 jumelage entre des villes
françaises et des villes allemandes nous
avons interviewé Christina langdezoti la
vice-présidente du jumelage entre
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et hsenburg mais
un jumelage à quoi ça sert
globalement je dirais ça sert à
promouvoir la coopération communale par
de la des frontières nationales et
encourager les échanges autour de la
culture et l'économie
il permet assez de favoriser les
rapprochements entre plusieurs cultures
on recherche un partage des valeurs et
des pratiques et de la mise en place des
changes de bons procédés
j'ajoute que historiquement les cheveux
ménages franco-allemand ont été un moyen
local de rapprocher les populations même
si c'est un peu oublié aujourd'hui les
60 ans du traité d'Elysée nous le
rappellerons l'année prochaine
quel type d'échanges sont proposés à
Charlesbourg c'est une jumelage de ville
qui concerne avant tout les deux villes
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et recherche
et si elles sont très actifs comme dans
ce cas ils organismes des projets
communs que ce soit des échanges entre
leurs employés ou apprentis ou par le
bien de programme d'erasmose plus nous
avons une la maison d'Europe ici la
chance d'avoir où ils organisent d'une
façon plus Ambit juste des rencontres
d'échanges de bonnes pratiques comme
j'ai déjà dit et sur des projets
similaires ensuite nous avons le côté
citoyen représenté par l'association des
Amis du cheminage Saint-Germain à
et dont je suis la vice-présidente son
but est comme évoqué d'organiser des
rencontres des membres allemands et
français pour mieux se connaître et de
faire des projets ensemble nous nous
retrouvons bien sur tous les cinq ans
pour fêter notre anniversaire mais il y
avait plusieurs rencontres en 2016 nous
sommes également donnés rendez-vous sur
les champs de bataille de la Grande
Guerre
en décembre 2017 nous avons accompagné
notre cœur Saint-Germain à Chaffin
Bourgue où il a donné un très bon
concert de Noël avec le printemps
et nous avons profité de cette occasion
pour retrouver nos amis du friendsky
c'est de visiter leur traditionnelle
marché de Noël et finalement en novembre
2019 nous sommes retrouvés à Berlin pour
fêter ensemble les 30 ans de la chute du
mur de Berlin de façon générale nous
proposons des échanges scolaires entre
les différentes collèges et Lucien lycée
qui sont directement organisés par les
collèges et lycées eux-mêmes et non pas
par les Amis du jumelage des échanges
sportifs comme par exemple les
randonneurs des cyclistes des groupes de
natation
comme j'ai déjà dit des musiciens comme
les chorales et des groupes
professionnels comme des pompiers et les
employés de nos de mairies comme évoqués
dans le cadre du programme
Erasmus plus
ils ont ainsi la possibilité de
pratiquer leurs activités dans un cadre
commun et découvrir une ville et son
mode de vie et partager leurs
expériences et leurs cultures
pourquoi vous êtes investi dans un
jumelage
je suis arrivé à Saint-Germain et
entre-temps c'est un petit peu devenu ma
ville je me sens très bien à sa chair à
en lait et du coup je me suis tournée
naturellement vers l'investissement dans
un
jumelage car je connais parfaitement les
deux cultures et le partage des valeurs
et le rapprochement des cultures et
depuis toujours quelque chose qui me
tient particulièrement à cœur
c'est un truc de vieux comment attirer
les plus jeunes je vous aborder un vrai
challenge il faut dire que avec les
longues journées scolaires pour les pour
les
français pour les élèves français c'est
pas facile de mobiliser en plus du temps
et de l'énergie pour s'investir dans un
cheminage
par ailleurs un cheminage ça motivait la
génération qui avait une conscience de
la guerre en Europe cela paraissait
désormais impossible malheureusement ce
n'est plus vrai et le cheminage trans
les cheveux mêlage trans européens sont
plus que jamais une nécessité
pour les jeunes qui participent les
jumelas sont bien dynamiques je vous
encourage d'ailleurs à visionner des
vidéos du groupe de hip-hop
franco-allemand page double du en
français il chante dans les deux langues
et ils ont gagné le Prix arenawa De
Gaulle c'est très cher très
enthousiasmant et c'est l'occasion de le
faire connaître un peu plus
en ce qui concerne le choumelage entre
acharfenburg le recrutement des jeunes
et une des priorités de la présidente
Regina Lecointe et la cessé de trouver
des idées pour attirer les jeunes à
l'intérieur du cheminage via des
sciences cinéma organisées avec les
lycées et en plus à travers des projets
communs organisés entre les lycées des
deux villes par exemple en novembre des
éco délégués d'un lycée de Saint-Germain
on contrôle homologue d'achat symbole
d'un voyage commun des deux villes à
Strasbourg donc je suis convaincue que
ce travail inlassable portera ses fruits
en tout cas il plante la graine pour la
future élève
zone Europe
le but de cette émission c'est aussi
d'apprendre à mieux se connaître et
l'équipe de radio Clank breit est allé
vous demander si vous connaissez bien
les artistes allemands
connaissez-vous des artistes allemands
alors je connais pas d'artistes mais mon
copain il en écoute c'est principalement
du rock allemand mais sinon
je sais pas Ghost kids je crois qu'il
chante en allemand mais c'est la seule
personne
[Musique]
je crois que l'artiste s'appelait
s'appelle du coup
c'est ce dont je me rappelle non j'en
connais pas mais comme l'Allemagne fait
partie des puissances mondiales et c'est
une grande puissance économique
forcément il y a des écrans des grands
artistes Tokio Hôtel de mon
époque voilà donc c'est vrai que c'était
surtout mon frère qui coûtait ça et puis
il me semble qu'il y avait tattoo aussi
voilà donc ça c'était de la musique de
ma jeunesse on va dire et puis après
sinon ça m'est déjà arrivé d'entendre
d'écouter du rap allemand mais je
saurais pas vous dire les noms des
groupes
mais malheureusement je connais pas mais
à partir d'aujourd'hui je vais chercher
à connaître
et l'équipe de radio Klang breit a voulu
aussi en savoir un petit peu plus sur
vos connaissances en matière de sportif
allemand
absolument pas par qui ils ont gagné la
coupe de nuit 14 je sais rien du tout
vraiment pas en 86
jours que je l'ai aimé grâce à lui
j'aime toutes les Allemands final depuis
quart de finale demi-finale jusqu'à
finale il a il a marqué son temps
jusqu'à maintenant c'est le 30 que les
gens parlent de lui
[Musique]
dans le sport l'Allemagne figure parmi
les grands nations sportifs et moi je
suis amoureux du ballon de football du
coup je connais le malsain l'équipe
nationale allemande et du coup je
connais beaucoup de footballeurs
allemands et par exemple j'aime surtout
le Bayern Munich avec l'arrivée de notre
Sadio national du coup je connais pas
mal de joueurs allemands par exemple
alors il y en a un c'est pas un Allemand
bah Ken Bower c'était un Allemand c'est
un très grand footballeur
ma jeunesse bon je crois qu'il y a
encore quelques efforts à faire nos
autres sens à reporters sont Lorie
Simonet et Théo ganiage de la cheville
bonjour bonjour vous êtes donc vous avez
notamment accompagné le groupe de radio
klangue bright au cours de ce séjour
pour recueillir leurs impressions alors
effectivement nous les avons suivi lors
de la visite de la Maison Jean Monnet à
Bazoches sur Guyonne Jean Monnet donc
l'un des pères fondateurs de l'Europe
regardez
[Musique]
nous sommes dans le berceau de l'Union
européenne c'est ici que Jean Monnet
illustre personnage français aura passé
de nombreuses années de sa vie tout au
long du 20e siècle il y aura reçu Robert
Schuman personnalité française avec qui
il a initié les prémices de l'Europe
mais malgré ça malgré toutes ces bonnes
actions il reste pour l'instant un
personnage peu connu de tous et c'est un
monsieur qui a fait beaucoup de choses
pour les autres
en sachant que c'est un monsieur qui
travaille toujours dans l'ombre et je
trouve ça dommage qu'on connaît pas plus
de sur mon nez globalement de tout ce
qu'il a fait pour vous alors ici on met
le passé le futur le passé par des
peintures des objets que j'emmenais à
utiliser tout au long de sa vie et le
futur avec des tablettes tactiles des
écrans géants des petits jeux qui
permettent de découvrir un peu plus sur
la vie du politique français de quoi
impressionner les visiteurs présents
pour être honnête je n'avais jamais
entendu parler de Jean Monnet avant
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment incroyable
d'être dans l'endroit dans lequel il a
vécu c'était un homme humble mais aussi
un visionnaire qui était l'un des pères
fondateurs de l'Union européenne l'UE
est d'ailleurs un des plus grands
projets réalisés aujourd'hui je suis
donc ravie qu'on soit venu ici et qu'on
est appris à connaître cette personne
cette maison Jean Monnet est située dans
la commune de
Bazoches-sur-Guyonne plus précisément
dans le hameau de houjarred elle est
ouverte 7 jours sur 7 et l'entrée est
gratuite plus d'informations sont à
retrouver sur le site internet
jeannet.eu et puis autre découverte pour
les jeunes d'achat finburg c'est France
Miniature à Élancourt en effet c'est un
parc de 5 hectares dans lequel elles ont
pu découvrir 117 monuments français
l'occasion de faire le tour de la France
en seulement quelques heures
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
visiter la France dans une seule et même
journée oui c'est possible et c'est ici
au parc France Miniature à Élancourt
dans les Yvelines tout a commencé en
1989 quant à l'impelleras et Thierry
coltier ont décidé de représenter le
patrimoine français dans un seul et même
endroit au final c'est en mai 1991 que
le parc a ouvert ses portes aux
visiteurs alors France Miniature c'est
l'occasion de découvrir en une journée
tout ce que la France compte de plus
beau à pied vous allez pouvoir vous
promener du Mont-Saint-Michel au Stade
de France faire quelques pas pour
rejoindre le port de La Rochelle et Fort
Boyard par exemple et puis aller
chercher le soleil en Méditerranée on va
découvrir parmi 117 monuments qui sont
réalisés au 1/30 tout ce qui est plus le
plus beau dans nos régions de France
l'idée c'est vraiment de proposer à nos
visiteurs une balade sympathique en
famille avec un décor ludique et amusant
au total 117 monuments déjà présenté en
30 fois plus petit que leur taille
réelle parmi eux la Tour Eiffel le
château de Chambord ou encore le Mont
Saint-Michel chaque année de nouvelles
maquettes font leur apparition dans le
décor et séduisent les visiteurs je
pense que le parc est vraiment bien mais
ce n'est pas la vraie France je préfère
aller grands monuments même s'il y a
beaucoup de répliques c'est ma première
fois en France donc tout était presque
nouveau pour moi à part la Tour Eiffel
ce que j'ai adoré ce sont les châteaux
anciens qui étaient en quelque sorte en
ruines mais j'ai aussi apprécié les
monuments plus modernes comme le Stade
de France par exemple
tous les ans France Miniature compte
environ 200 000 visiteurs et propose en
plus des activités comme des manèges des
attractions et des expériences
interactives réouverture le 8 avril
prochain
[Musique]
dès lundi sur Radio sensation c'est une
semaine spéciale franco-allemande que
nous vous proposerons avec une série de
rencontres et d'interviews nous allons
en découvrir quelques extraits et on
commence par Hans zietter Lucas il est
ambassadeur d'Allemagne en France je
pense que le traite et l'ex-chapelle a
encore élargi le champ d'action
entre la France et l'Allemagne en ce qui
concerne la coopération entre nos
sociétés civile y compris la jeunesse et
le fond citoyen donc c'est vraiment à
mon avis une déjà maintenant donc il est
clair que c'est une mesure
initiative très réussie parce qu'avec ce
fond on peut vraiment soutenir beaucoup
de contacts très informel n'est-ce pas
entre les initiatives en France et en
Allemagne donc ça ça a vraiment
c'était une excellente idée de créer de
fond
et en plus n'est ce pas aussi renforcer
donc le travail de l'offrage ça permet
des relations frontalement ce sont les
contacts entre entre les gens entre les
peuples entre les sociétés civiles ça
c'est pour élargir un petit peu cette
amitié qui ne doit pas être que
qu'institutionnel et que entre
guillemets entre les gouvernements les
assemblées mais que l'ensemble des
citoyens s'empare aussi de cette
question
absolument
à mon avis c'est vraiment la base de la
de la relation franco-allemande et y
compris les jumelages n'est ce pas entre
entre les communes les villes les
régions
à mon avis c'est tout à fait central
donc les contacts entre le gouvernement
c'est bien mais nécessitent pas il faut
vraiment aussi donc des des milliers de
contact entre entre les Français et les
Allemands les jeunes les plus âgés dans
tous les niveaux un autre extrait à
présent on retrouve Franck groeninger
auteur de 12 Franck Reichs les aventures
d'un Allemand à Paris c'est aux éditions
altère publishing
en fait l'idée est venue
d'un carton que j'ai trouvé que je
voulais ranger parce qu'on a vendu la
maison familiale et dans cette danse
carton j'ai trouvé une carte postale de
mon grand-père me voici la carte postale
qui a donc vécu avant la deuxième guerre
mondiale et qui avait écrit à Paris et
c'est là que je me suis commencé à j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser un petit peu à
ce parcours et je me suis dit ça fait
quand même 25 ans que je suis en France
donc j'ai un peu voulu faire le point et
j'ai commencé à écrire alors mais
d'abord repartons en arrière vous l'avez
dit donc vos grands-parents vêtus ont
déjà en France avant vous mais qu'est-ce
qu'il était venu faire en France c'est
mon grand-père qui a travaillé
en France parce qu'il travaillait pour
un juif et les Allemands les Allemands
avaient les nazis au pouvoir donc il a
quitté la France mais ils ne sont pas
restés très longtemps parce que quand la
guerre a commencé il fallait rentrer en
Allemagne pour ne pas être interdit donc
et ils ont parlaient pas tellement
parce que je pense par plus d'heures
donc c'est comme un mystère qui est
resté là-dessus ils étaient restés
combien de temps en France vos
grands-parents
alors quand on est un petit allemand en
Allemagne quelle image on a de la France
du pays d'à côté
un petit allemand dans les années 70
donc il y a pas internet etc donc
c'était très
cliché glamour ce que j'ai connu c'est
Mireille Mathieu comme chanteuse voilà
c'est c'est ça reste très cliché quand
même les jumelages on en parlait tout à
l'heure on y reviendra avec Denis
Lemarchand il est maire adjoint et
l'encours et l'encours justement une
ville jumelée avec deux communes
allemandes là au bar et graff et nine
nition en 2023 ce sera les 60 ans du
traité de l'Élysée qui avait été signé
donc entre les général de Gaulle et le
chancelier Conrad Adenauer une année
particulièrement importante donc l'année
prochaine pour tous les jumelages
franco-allemand puisque ça a été un peu
ce traité de lisait le point de départ
finalement de cette dynamique qu'est-ce
que vous retenez vous de ce traité alors
tout à fait clairement l'objectif fort
de ce traité était de rapprocher les
peuples et puisque donc c'est deux
grands personnages que sont
avait bien perçu que
en étant voisin et en étant en combat
quasi permanent 1870 14-18 et 39 45 ça
pouvait pas continuer comme ça et que la
seule solution pour stopper c'est
engrenage c'était de rapprocher les
peuples et donc l'idée essentielle de ce
traité de l'Elysée c'est de mettre en
place des structures qui permettent
effectivement aux gens de se rencontrer
et donc ça a débouché comme vous l'avez
finement signalé sur les jumelages mais
c'était un des objectifs ça n'était pas
le seul mais l'objectif principal
c'était le rapprochement des peuples
alors à la fois sur les plans
économiques culturels sportif etc et
donc autant une compétition sportive
ne pose aucune difficulté autant le
rapprochement des peuples est
indispensable et pour ça la bonne
solution c'est que les gens se
rencontrent directement est-ce que 60
ans après on peut on peut dire que ça a
été un succès alors pour moi la réponse
est oui ça a été un succès puisque c'est
ce qui en même ce qui a conduit derrière
à la création de l'Europe c'est à dire
que l'Europe est née effectivement avec
6 pays comme vous le savez dont la
France et l'Allemagne bon l'Italie et
puis le Benelux et ça a été
effectivement
un moment très fort parce que et à
débouché sous le le travail qui a été
fait par Jean Monnet qui habite tout
près de d'Élancourt d'ailleurs qui
habitait tout près des gens courent a
lancé effectivement ce qui est devenu au
départ la communauté économique du
charbon et de l'acier et en fait là
c'était donc le volet économique qui
avait été
mis en valeur mais qui là aussi
s'appuyait sur un rapprochement
à la fois des entreprises et des
personnes qui travaillaient dans les
entreprises puis façon Top Gun mais sans
Tom Cruise car il n'était pas disponible
c'est notre journaliste Jessie Willens
qui s'est rendu à la base aérienne 105 à
Évreux pour nous faire découvrir
l'escadron franco-allemand de transport
nous sommes à l'escadron franco-allemand
c'est 130 g à Évreux qui a été inauguré
en mars 2021 et je suis avec le
lieutenant-colonel Mike bonjour bonjour
alors quand vous êtes arrivés sur la
base comment ça s'est comment s'est
passé votre arrivée justement sur cette
base militaire
je suis arrivé ici à la base 105 en
avril 2021 et j'ai commencé à travailler
nous avons ouvert l'élément de soutien
national en avril avec l'aide de la
partie française et nous avons continué
à préparer l'arrivée des soldats
allemands ici à Évreux et comment s'est
passé l'adaptation avec avec les
militaires français sur sur la base
lancement
ce n'était pas du tout un problème car
ici à Évreux nous avons reçu un soutien
incroyable du camp mais aussi de la
ville on était en toute tranquillité et
nous nous sommes sentis très à l'aise
dans la région dès le début nous avons
pu commencer notre travail avec beaucoup
de soutien et cela dès notre arrivée
est-ce que vos familles ont pu vous
suivre justement quand vous êtes parti
pour venir en France
la plupart des familles ne sont arrivées
que le 21 août nous parlons d'environ 20
familles qui sont arrivées ici à Évreux
c'est famille ont ensuite amené leurs
enfants à l'école et c'était bien sur un
défi pour elle mais surtout pour les
enfants qui devaient apprendre le
français on a eu des problèmes
relativement gérables c'était surtout
avec la barrière de la langue mais comme
je l'ai dit nous avons reçu du soutien
incroyable de la part de la base mais
aussi des écoles après la première année
nous pouvons maintenant dire que
l'intégration c'est extrêmement bien
déroulée nos enfants parlent de mieux en
mieux le français et les conversations
deviennent de plus en plus fluides et
quels sont les avantages d'un d'un
escadron franco-allemand quels sont les
objectifs
les objectifs et les principes de cet
escadron sont basés sur l'amitié et sur
la coopération et son avantage est bien
évidemment le fait qu'il soit binational
ici nous avons 10 avions c'est une
petite flotte donc mais nous opérons
ensemble car nous avons différents
niveaux d'expérience le but est
d'apporter aux autres d'apprendre les
uns des autres et bien évidemment de
faire preuve d'unité en matière de
sécurité et de défense entre la France
et l'Allemagne quelle a été votre
ressenti face à la création de de cet
escadron franco-allemand
j'ai découvert la création d'un relais
binational en 2016 et j'ai trouvé le
projet absolument intéressant j'avais
postulé à ce moment-là et je pense que
c'était la bonne décision à Évreux nous
essayons de mener à bien ce nouveau
projet et je vous assure qu'ici allemand
ou français nous sommes tous très très
engagés des interviews à retrouver en
intégralité lors de la semaine spéciale
franco-allemande sur Radio sensation ça
se passera du 5 au 9 décembre à 13h30 et
à 19h30 c'est la fin de ce zone Europe
également consacré aux relations
franco-allemande est réalisé avec le
soutien du fond citoyen franco-allemand
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur notre site Internet ou sur
notre application radio sensation et
aussi sur TV 78 à bientôt pour un
nouveau numéro
zone Europe sur sensation avec le
soutien financier du fond citoyen
franco-allemand